je m'appelle victoire et abalo dinart je
suis russe victoria 27 ans la nouvelle
coach adjointe des cheerleaders des
templiers d'elancourt la russe domicilié
à montfort l'amaury depuis quelques
semaines a été embauchée suite à une
annonce postée par les dirigeants sur
facebook
la sportive espère transmettre son
expérience à ce club créé en 2012 a
ctuellement winehouse est il
j'ai commencé le cheerleading 18 ans
j'ai fais une équipe avec ma meilleure
amie dans notre université et ensuite
j'ai intégré des clubs de cheerleading
c'est vraiment une grande étape pour moi
d'avoir été une chaîne leader en russie
et maintenant d'aider cette équipe de
france
la cheerleader travaillera en binôme
avec lorie fournier coach dans la
structure depuis trois ans je suis plus
spécialisés dans le cheer dancing donc
tout ce qui va être chorégraphie et c
est s est vrai qu'elle a vraiment des
bonnes bases en cheerleading purée en
termes de stunt et c'est donc elle va
elle va nous apporter vraiment ce qui
nous manquait pour la section alors les
stones en fait ça va être les porter ça
va être les pyramides ce genre de chose
qu'un conseil à des choses un peu
gymnastique pour sa première séance
d'entraînement ce lundi 28 novembre
victoria dirigé dix filles âgées de 15 à
24 ans elle nous a un peu aidé à revoir
les bases qui au final
était pas pu mal parce que on avait pris
quelques mauvaises habitudes je suis
flydoc je suis en haut je me fais porter
en fait et elle m'a appris plus gai mais
enfin comment bien gainer comment bien
se tenir sur les portes et la nouvelle
coach désormais deux mois pour peaufiner
les porter en vue de la saison de
football américain qui débutera le 21
janvier prochain domicile pour les
templiers d'elancourt